Don Trump jr. joins us first your first
interview since the hearing yesterday I
think soft for coming on so it is what
was your react what was I mean I think
that tweet sums it up pretty well but
elaborate on what you thought of it well
listen I really think it does it speaks
for itself I mean I'm watching a guy
that led an investigation was the head
of the FBI was a former prosecutor spent
two years and almost 50 million dollars
investigating it and I see a congressman
ask let's talk about fusion GPS I've
never heard of it I mean that'd be like
a builder talking about not
understanding what a foundation is do
not even have a finite understanding of
how this all started
tells the American public everything
they need a node Tucker this was a hoax
set up by the Democrats from moment
number one it wasn't true this
investigation was about trying to figure
out what happened it was trying to back
into the result that they wanted they
couldn't do that because there was
nothing there but they drugged people
through the mud for two years they
spread it in the media ad nauseam
without fail you you saw the year prior
host your guest earlier today saying the
same things he still may be working with
Putin yes because Donald Trump needed to
leave his lifestyle of what will pretty
call luxury to go work for the Russians
rather than because he's sick of what's
going on in American politics because
he's sick of politicizing every single
aspect and being willing to ruin
people's lives send American lives to
fight wars for things that don't exist
all of this nonsense that you talk about
because there's no accountability in
Washington DC and I think the American
people finally saw it that this man who
was the lead of the major the largest
investigation in American history really
the largest hoax at this point he didn't
have a fundamental understanding of not
only where it began but what was even
involved how it took place ultimately I
think the American public saw that he
was put in there as a figurehead because
he was the former leader of the FBI he
was a decorated marine and that he would
do what's right but no one's talking
about this guy put in nineteen leftist
Hillary Clinton donor lawyers
all they worked on the Clinton campaign
they went to her what would have been
inauguration party they were there
celebrating it he had no idea who was
running the ship the inmates were
running the asylum and those inmates
were the Democrat Party who are doing
whatever they could to destroy my
father's presidency because they see
that he's actually getting things done
he's actually getting things done for
the American people he's actually
delivering on the promises that he made
and what I'd love to see as an American
and someone who's really been drug
through the mud myself in this whole
hoax is I'd love to see the Democrats
actually do something for Americans for
a change not for their power base not
for the political elite not for their
nonsense crazy that they're running with
these days but for actual hardworking
Americans how about getting the USMC a
passed through Congress how about
working on an infrastructure bill how
about doing anything other than trying
to destroy my father who's actually
delivering for the people that he said
he would deliver so we all people need
to see two things Jerry Nadler is on
another Channel I think right as we
speak saying more subpoenas so this will
I you know perish according to mr.
Nadler continue were you surprised to
hear the Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi say this afternoon to us that she
still believes the president United
States is working for Russia Speaker of
the House no Tucker because this is all
they have they've banked their entire
reputation on it remember it started off
as collusion then it was going to be
obstruction then it was a cover-up then
it's gonna be you know what Southern
District of New York then it you know
Mahler is gonna be the savior we're
gonna get them this time
they just keep doubling down again
because there's no one that's willing to
hold them accountable you know maybe you
maybe Sean in the next hour a few people
but the mainstream media will still by
and large run with just about anything
that they tell them they don't have to
be a vac based there doesn't have to be
any evidence as long as they say it
that's all that they need because
mainstream media has become the de-facto
marketing division of the DSC that is
very clear that is not an overstatement
Don Trump jr. great to see you tonight
thank you
Thank You tiger